in the comic Batman is often described
as a peak human the idea is that he
doesn't have anything powers of search
like Superman but that he represents the
pinnacle of what's possible for human
being in terms of their athletic
performance their intelligence their
knowledge their skill sets and that part
of what makes them so compelling so
inspiring because we think that
theoretically anyone could become Batman
that's what I want to address in this
video is there really such thing as a
peak human and if so would a peak human
come close to Batman in terms of their
skill and strength and speed etc always
be just too far removed from what's
possible if it is possible to come
Batman how would you go about doing it
and how could we go about doing it in a
way that wouldn't completely ruin our
lives and call us to die very very early
[Music]
so I've touched on this subject once
before I made a Batman workout for you
and that was quite popular
that was Batman has quite the same video
editing skills all the same equipment
though so I thought I'd go over it again
not only that but that was the Batman
workout videos bits fun and also it
didn't cover what it really takes to
come Batman because Batman isn't just a
super strong guy and rendering part he's
also a guy who has a huge skill set and
an impossible like cube and but that was
what I wanted to address was possible to
come Batman in every respect or how
close could we really come something
Batman super strong and I'll touch on
that again in a moment but one of the
things that came up a lot in the
comments on that previous video was his
martial arts prowess because I was
living today as to whether Batman knew
all the martial art or only 127 martial
arts either way pretty impressive I
think you'll agree but I'm pretty
certain there's no way he could possibly
know all of the martial arts obviously
depends on which comment you read
because if a fictional character and it
obviously depends on which writer is
writing at the time and what suits the
plot but in reality you couldn't really
learn every martial arts because we
couldn't even really define what a
martial art is martial arts cropping up
all the time and even within all the
major martial arts you got like karate
you then have your sub styles like shows
a car and water room go guru so I learn
what a root karate which included
grappling and some elements of pushing
hands words my friends it shows a car
which is a much much more harder than
more strikes focused version of karate
so they're very different so and even
within shaky Carlin's what really has
subsidized and people branch off and
create their own in the Christopher
Nolan film Batman uses a particular
martial art style called the KP fighting
method and this would vary use of time
and I believe it's been abandoned since
and that's the style of martial art that
wouldn't even existed when BAM was
invented so the point if you can
possibly know
because they're constantly being added
to and passed they want a martial art is
only one you know you know wrestling
lien they're Mexican wrestling we can
take a Cuero you know Tai Chi you know
it's hard to say that all those things
would be relevant or useful to but he
only had a very wide martial art
experience then on top of this Batman
also has a ton of other skills a ton of
other knowledge
he's probably ambidextrous makes sense
the other use both hands equally in a
fight you know forensic he's probably
polyglot me they need to speak multiple
languages he can code break he can
probably program he is certainly mention
lyrically talking supple resided graves
its business he can pick the locks you
can throw nine he can climb the ropes
it's probably greatest rock climbing
there's just such a huge range of
different things you know and the
question is could you really study all
those martial arts and learn all that
stuff at once and the answer is it would
definitely be very difficult so there's
a great video on the origin of Batman by
the imaginary axis that looks into a lot
of how Batman's training was depicted in
the comments etc and they suggest that
in order to have learned so much in such
a short space of time you might have
used a specific sleep schedule called
the uberman schedule this involves
breaking the sleep into short little
bursts of illustrator really rather than
just sleeping eight hours to the light
and that way in theory you can get by on
much less sleep so that right away
takers hours during the day from 14 or
18 all the way up to 20 or 22 now we've
got more time in the day to learn more
and while Batman's whole bag is a DQ
Merlin doesn't leave superpowers a
genetic mutation that really exists in
some humans might give someone an edge
if they were trying to replicate
Batman's accomplishments and mutation on
the gene be easy to for instance has
recently been discovered to cause people
to need a lot less sleep they can get by
on four to six hours of sleep instead of
eight and perform completely normally
I'd also suggest that you probably would
have learned
learning strategies so it is changing
the comics that you learn key reading
for instance and it developed a
photographic memory in order to memorize
much more so already taking in a lot
more information a lot more quickly and
then Batman might view specific learning
strategies in order to absorb this
information more quickly there's the
fireman technique for instance which
involved learning to teach them on
something they're going through it set
up set to make sure you properly
understand and consolidate that
information then there's Tim Ferriss is
disc method I'm not suggesting that
Batman use these specific methods that
I'm saying that if somebody wanted to
learn more things more quickly they
might also use this kind of strategy
likewise if someone was that set on
learning such a huge range of different
subjects then they might use nootropics
of user subjects i've covered on this
channel before that you have basically
brain drugs which enhance your
concentration your memory your focus
even your creativity in some pages I've
discussed this on the channel a lot and
I pointed out that none of them is a
perfect solution in fact I don't really
recommend many of them other than the
kind of natural nutrients and things
like that they can just support brain
functions but if you're Batman and you
didn't care so much about your health or
your getting along with people then you
might be tempted to use it as a strategy
to learn faster for instance modafinil
is supposedly used by a lot of the
highest performing CEOs and
entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley well you
could use modafinil in order to split
left it was originally developed as a
narcoleptic drug so you could use that
to sleep left and at the same time
increase your focus and your memory to
learn quicker again I'm not recommending
that you do it and I'm not saying that
this is what Batman would have done I'm
just saying that if a realized person
want to absorb this much information in
a short space of time waters become a
matter of multiple subjects before they
reach their third key then you probably
want to combine all these different
strategies learning techniques
nootropics and avoiding sleep
Batman would also likely have wanted to
increase his brain plasticity to be
sensitive to brain to gain new
connections to grow new neurons and
generally to allow you to learn more
things more quickly this is greater when
you're younger and as your older brain
plasticity slows down so you can boost
it in a number of different ways and
I've discussed this on my channel - you
can do it with transcranial direct
current stimulation you can do it with
certain nutrients certain fruit pick in
one recent study valproate
response to massively enhance brain
plasticity even allowing adults to gains
perfect pitch through training which is
pretty impressive anybody want to want
to go that far the turmeric can slightly
increase your brain plasticity as camp
magnesium three units and neither of
those is going to cause any major side
effects so now we have a bat man who has
hats got the genetic mutation that
allows them to sleep less he doesn't
even lose a man scheduled to need to
sleep even less he's probably started at
a very young age he's in hearts brain
capacity he is using various learning
techniques like defying wind technique
he developed speed reading and
photographic memory and all these things
were allowing to learn a lot more
quickly whether or not he can still
learn that much by the time you hitting
the streets is doing is round as Batman
is unsure but certainly the idea that
you need 10,000 hours whatever is to
come a master might be an idea that you
can faster with and negotiate with and
perhaps using all those strategies he
could have learned more martial arts and
more skills in less time wholly savvy
but Batman didn't just learn all these
things he did it all while building the
perfect body ultimate strength speed
stamina reaction time so you have to do
all that was learning as well and you
need to use rather intense training get
your neurosis achieve all the peace the
comics showing achieving
and yeah that would likely kill you
because now you've got barely any time
left music you're not sleeping you're
not recovering and you're just trading
falls to the wall if you need the book
the Batman file the details a rough idea
of what his workout would look like and
it involved him doing huge amounts of
compound movements with heavy weight
then going from massive long run all on
the same day and doing various types of
calisthenics rock climbing rings it bag
hedge bag work combining all this often
multiple sessions in a single day and
not really having any time to rest when
you're doing with the same kind of
stretching etc so could you really do
all that at the same time as learning
all that well there are certain
techniques we can happen to speed up
your recovery
obviously there's supplements in the
book I think it's called becoming Batman
possibility of a superhero or something
like that
it's postulated that eat them in my for
thousands plus calories a day just to
give themselves the energy to do all
this training and or just learning it
also need some huge amounts of protein
you probably want to take that in a very
bioavailable source boom and now I'm in
my vehicle the bio mobile okay so
actually my wife and I call it the
Duchess because it's so old it's stately
anyway I just wanted to say that there
are also many supplements you could use
in order to gain more energy and to
enhance your recovery from your training
I have talked about these a lot on this
channel as well for example cordyceps
that's a very useful supplement for
preventing adrenal fatigue possibly
increasing testosterone lutein seems to
be a very useful supplement for
increasing energy for your mitochondria
as well as possibly increasing brain
plasticity another good one is cacao or
any form of vitamin C which will help
you with recovery and preventing illness
and that something else Batman would
have to do it has to really strengthen
and fortify your immune system cold
showers can help you to do that
as well generally he can't get ill ever
to could kind of an ill Batman and he'd
probably never recover after the amount
of abuse he put his body through there's
obviously plenty more creatine and make
a screed fatty acid everything like that
coenzyme q10 you probably spend a whole
fortune on supplements increases energy
and then if I wanna enhances animalism
in other ways you might also use
contrast therapy hot and cold in order
to speed up his healing from wounds and
from his training you know the same way
to some athletes do and I touched on
this in my Batman workout video he would
quite likely give you some kind of
steroid again in the comics he doesn't
except that one time I use the imaginary
drugs called venom and I'm saying as a
character you wouldn't be but if you
were someone who is genuinely trying to
become Batman even care about sexual
health you just want to become the most
powerful person then yeah you probably
use steroids I mean Batman doesn't care
about having a long healthy life he
cares about being as powerful to can
wipe up crime on the streets in the
short term so this is this imaginary
person
Batman is someone who doesn't do all
those things in order to accomplish
everything he's done either you know an
ideal he's not supposed to be realistic
he is the best that human can be and
that includes his morals so he doesn't
use drugs of any kind then you have
regular humans it just couldn't
accomplish it but if you wants to be and
close the Batman you could be willing to
sacrifice everything and not only what
you have to give up all your sleep and
all it read also probably what habits
they're always in order to recover that
quickly and to become that strong
without that training just crushing
because not only be doing all that that
is then going out and exciting on the
streets as well causing yourself huge
injury so yes if you were that serious
about becoming Batman it would probably
be possible to become pretty darn close
by dedicating your entire life to
learning training and giving up relate
[ __ ] in your business you need some kind
of stream of income that make you didn't
have to spend it out day in office for
example Batman inherited a fortune and
that the running of its business or
someone else you also probably need to
live with scars and aching joints and
likely you'd need to do drugs
so yes the coming Batman is not really
achievable for most people so just how
close because a regular person comes
becoming Batman what would you have to
do in order to be a bit more like Batman
well first of all you need to do some
kind of training program to focus not
only on building strength in size and
appearance but general performance and
this is something we're seeing a lot
more these days with CrossFit or the one
you like it the whole objectivism of
training cross modalities that you're
faster and stronger I'm interested in
using the Dybbuk techniques for building
strength such as static contraction
which I've talked about a lot on this
video overcoming isometric system look
techniques used by I like to recruit
sleep to build how without necessarily
building body size and speed etc on top
of that DC's your martial art and if you
then take a lot of time to your training
and to martial arts etc then you would
probably want to do some kind of job
where once again you wouldn't give up
too much energy on too much time so
again for something that I'm interested
in so if you watch one of my recent
vlogs I've talked about house working
from home and running an online business
it allows me to then take bit more times
my training and my hobbies in my
interest basically allowing you to you
my demented aims to become more like
that man
I also introduced something else into my
training recently because I'm interested
in becoming more like that man so I
worked out five days a week before they
do those regular training I do a
football workouts followed by legs and
abs followed by cardiovascular wake up
etc so day five is now my skills
training game because I write on my
website that stuff I'm interested in in
my research things like the coming
ambidextrous jumping higher running
faster climbing techniques parkour etc
but when you're going to really get the
time to do all those things well that's
why I've dedicated my fifth workout this
is what I do things like flexibility
training or coordination or reflexes or
left-handed training so on this one day
I do all the kind of cool fun stuff that
won't necessarily build muscle or create
micro tears or metabolic stress but it
will allow me to hone other skills that
people wouldn't necessarily have great
strength etc I've only just started but
lots done and I train horsepower
obviously I'm not seriously required to
come like Batman so yes I would much
rather spend the day doing rock climbing
with just my hands and then some less
kind of training rather than doing some
boring preset workout routines so I'm
enjoying that and that's something that
I recommend you if you're interested in
you know developing useful athletic
prowess rather than jet muscle to show
and of course you need to keep learning
keep discovering new things this is
something to do to your job as a writer
I'm fortunate so I often get paid to
learn subjects I don't know often ones
I'm interested in and I spend a lot my
free time in programming languages
taking on new challenges etc my favorite
technique for learning more quickly is
to know what you want to achieve and
then work backwards from there having a
goal in mind helps you to learn faster
don't
instead of learning to program in Java
no one want to make them Java and then
learn the coding in order to make that
thing it makes a lot more sense when you
have it in that context it's always
working on projects and that was helping
me to learn these things obviously
always writing about subjects like
ambidexterity or playing classes people
from my website as well and on top of
that I would highly recommend that
everyone be meditation it's something
I've only just recently started but if
you want more energy to do more and also
the kind of mental discipline and
improve brain plasticity as we discussed
and focused then brain plasticity will
help you to accomplish that you need a
lot of discipline to be like that man
you need a lot of discipline to fix that
any training regime and that's why
learning to focus and to keep in mind
quietly free from distractions for
wireless gentleness everyone can benefit
from and it does give me a boost in
energy originally I recently watched a
video where celebrities were talking
about how important education was to
them and many months that have given a
boost in energy that allows them to
accomplish much more science Belden's
tip 0 remember was saying greatest human
meditation was something that let him
work harder longer and he thought that
if he has learned to meditate sooner he
would have continued to put out a lot
more work for a lot longer before kind
of reaching burnout the band of mind a
lot of us are kind of burned that modern
life always pile a ton of crazy training
on top of it using meditation could be
just the quality to increase your
training etc also for the average Joe
looking to do his best to become as
close to that man as possible without
sacrificing his entire life supplements
a great way he'd get more energy oshi
and thereby get more done whether that's
focusing on their projects and their
learning or whether it's their training
and getting more out of themselves so
the supplement that I would recommend if
you're on a limited budget and you just
want to enhance your recovery and your
strengths and your energy levels
probably creatine certainly protein
shake whey protein lutein I seem to be a
big fan of right now omega-3 fatty acid
cordyceps mushroom and again you can
look at all the videos on this channel
for more inspiration on different
stuffings
to boost energy etc I do not recommend
we sleep less you're going to need your
sleep for recovery for building muscles
and cementing the things you learn
during the day that's when the most
brain plasticity occurs what I would say
is try and increase the quality of your
sleep so that you have more energy
during the day and maybe you can get by
on a little less one supplement it might
be able to help you do this is magnesium
three and eight which helps you get off
to sleep and also increases the same
plasticity during sleep and helps you
raise testosterone especially if you
also combine that with some zinc as a
vitamin b6 so that's something can Trey
finally have some kind of goal some kind
of drive because in a balanced imaginary
character but the writers recognize that
most people aren't going to train like
that is right here's the focus with a
lot of the story
what is it drive and obviously for him
it's revenge and justice and a fear of
bat and this is what given this kind of
the same drives to come better and
become stronger and sacrifices
relationship into the body etc in the
suit of Batman you're not Batman you
probably don't eat crying quite the same
degree as Batman and so you can read
your own driving your own motivation
even goals you're passionate about and
this can work towards and I will driving
towards that improvement and ultimately
that might not mean that you need to
learn forensics or lock-picking you can
come to Batman of your own life by
becoming that passionate and that driven
learning that much training that hard
having that same single mindfulness and
accomplishing whatever it is that you
set your mind to and that's how you can
really become Batman in your own life
[Music]
so guys hope you found this video useful
or interesting if you did then please
check out the article on my website
where I go into more detail and even
more in-depth discussion and please
consider leaving the lights down below
maybe leaving a comment love to hear
your thoughts if there's anything I
missed or any tip you have and please
let me hear them and stay tuned for the
next one I've got a whole lot more on
the way and they'll be talking about old
time strongman techniques Bruce Lee's
diet rail training through virtual
reality the GPB pockets or productivity
and tons more so yes thanks a ton for
watching I'll see in the next one and
bye for now
of course the real way to become Batman
IRL is to subscribe to the pioneer